let's talk a little bit about social
democracy and populism today many of you
know that my political leanings are
toward social democracy social democracy
is of course a mixed economy it is a
capitalist system in the sense that you
have private ownership of businesses
some people are richer than others etc
but it is a capitalist system that is
actually well regulated it's used the
profits the fruits of capitalism are
used to ensure that nobody standard of
living falls too low to ensure everyone
has health care to ensure people have
access to education etc and this is a
system that sometimes has overlap with
populism and sometimes it doesn't and
what I want to talk about today are the
concerns I have that the move towards
populism over the last few years within
the left may lend itself to people being
bamboozled and to the perversion of
left-wing goals ideals and most
importantly of actually getting
left-wing stuff done increasingly we are
seeing populism become popularized and
there's a really interesting article in
the Journal of democracy called populism
and the decline of social democracy it's
by sherry Berman and Maria Segovia and
it argues that it's actually a danger to
democracy and to the left to see
populism replace social democracy and it
outlines some of the risks that are
implicit in that so let's start to dig
into it and the main concern I have with
populism is that it's too easy to use
populist rhetoric to bamboozle or trick
people because there is left wing
populism and right wing populism whereas
social democracy is decidedly left a
much clearer cut set of ideas and policy
prescriptions and much more
straightforward
as a means for achieving progressive
change to put it simply populism is a
political approach that wants to appeal
to ordinary people who feel that their
concerns their priorities are ignored or
disregarded by established elite groups
elite groups could be those in
government it could be those in
positions of power and corporations etc
rich people whatever so as you can
already see that is a broad enough
movement that that could be a left wing
or a right wing movement now there's an
academic expert on the issue of left
versus right wing populism his name is
Federico Finkelstein he is a fellow
Argentinean like me hilariously his dad
has known my dad for like decades from
Argentina we've interviewed Federico on
the show before and he has expertly
drawn the distinctions for us between
left-wing and right-wing populism but it
is very important to understand that
although there is no question of a huge
divide between left and right wing
populism the rhetoric is often very
similar and right wing ideology can be
cloaked and hidden as generic populism
in some very deceptive ways look at
Donald Trump's 2016 campaign that was a
right-wing populist campaign and here's
why it can be a great tool for deception
left-wing and right-wing populism both
take advantage of economic insecurity
and cultural anxiety of different kinds
to justify their own existence both left
and right wing populism often will point
to corruption and cronyism as a source
for what needs to be changed in our
societies not wrongly in principle both
left and right wing populism often push
this idea of us versus them but they are
very different us and very different
then right for someone like Bernie
Sanders us versus them is we instead of
I it's a politics of let's break up the
big banks it's the people against the
big banks let's deal with health
insurance companies let's deal with big
corporations and it's a good message
there's no question about it
for someone like Donald Trump us versus
them is us Americans instead of those
Mexican rapists and Middle Eastern
terrorists it's rich businessmen like me
who will fix your problems instead of
career politicians even if Trump ends up
hiring a lot of those same career
politicians it's trade deals that are
good for us instead of trade deals that
are good for China and Mexico except
when he passes those trade deals they're
terrible for American workers so indeed
when you look at the history of populism
populism is rooted in or comes from
totalitarianism that doesn't mean
populism is totalitarianism please don't
misquote me but populism can turn
authoritarian much more easily than
social democracy can look for example at
Venezuela where the shabbos regime now
Maduro has turned the rhetoric of
left-wing populism into authoritarianism
where the country cannot trust the
judiciary the country's resources have
been raped and pillaged for the benefit
of the few and the persistent paulla
poverty of the many you know the story
so what's my point my point is not that
left wing populism is bad in fact it's
not bad the point is that populism is
very easy to pervert and to trick people
with because the rhetoric of left and
right wing populism is often similar in
many ways and the line between true
progressive populism and centrist
populism and right-wing populism and
getting into authoritarianism it's often
blurry and gray and we're seeing that
with Donald Trump we've seen it in other
places as well now let's contrast this
with social democracy it's much more
difficult to pervert social democracy
it's much more difficult to trick people
with social democracy you could run on
social democracy and then just abandon
it but it would be very very obvious
there's really no way to do the rhetoric
of social democracy run on the policies
in social democracy and then slide into
a Thorat Arianism without people
noticing we're also seeing unfortunately
some on what we call the revolutionary
left actually fuel the shift
from social democracy into populism
which can be very quickly turned against
us and end up dividing the left very
badly and the risk is populism can go in
very undemocratic directions social
democracy really can't I mean ok we can
imagine some way in which it might but
for as long as it remains social
democracy it's not going to become
undemocratic and then let's go beyond
that not only do I think that replacing
social democracy with populism can be
dangerous to the Democratic
underpinnings of society I don't think
that it will really help the left long
term in the United States to move in the
direction of populism and away from
social democracy very often you'll hear
people on the Left say you know
right-wing populism has been on the
increase you see this in its
nationalistic implications
implementations in Europe you see it
under Donald Trump social democracy has
just failed it's been tough to get it
going in the United States let's adopt
our spin on populism but do it with
different prescriptions we blame the
problems on different actors of course
but the prescriptions that we often see
from left populism aren't really great
ones it's stuff like let's reclaim
nationalism and make it something good
for everyone for people of all races and
ethnicities will do nationalism but the
progressive way it hasn't worked and I
don't see any indication that it will
it's too easy to pervert that and for
bad actors to take advantage and you end
up in this revolutionary rabbit hole
that hurt Bernie in 2020 hated or liked
it it did not help Bernie Sanders in
2020 social democracy is specific
policies less wrapped up in an ideology
that can be perverted health care to
everyone let's figure out how to do it
paid parental and sick leave universal
early education increase the child tax
credit make it more affordable to go to
college and trade school reduce
incarceration legalize cannabis expand
government infrastructure spending tax
capital gains at a higher rate and
create some higher tax brackets it's
much more difficult to pervert that
stuff because it has less red or
Rick around it which becomes this fluid
squishy thing which is the case with
populism so my feeling right now is not
that populism is bad when it's actual
progressive populism my feeling is the
left has more to gain from social
democracy then it has to gain from the
rhetoric of left populism which so far
has not gone very far disagree with me
this is an important discussion to have
and when we think about you know
everybody's talking about why did Bernie
lose and who should be the torchbearers
of the progressive movement going
forward and there's a little bit of
discussion of you know maybe democratic
socialists wasn't a good term for Bernie
to adopt maybe the revolutionary
language wasn't useful but we actually
should go further and we should have a
deeper conversation about the move away
from social democracy from the
progressive left and towards the
rhetoric of populism even if not the
implementations of any policy I have I'm
open to having my mind changed this is
where I am right now I want to hear from
you